keep in mind these are all rough figures
but I asked chat GPT and it told me that
the average person spends six to eight
hours sitting this goes up to 10 to 12
hours for those in sedentary jobs by
doing the maths we can then work out
this is 2190 to 2920 hours per year and
to put that in perspective that's
anything between 25 and 33 of our entire
lives conversely I looked at a step
count survey from Stanford University
and by extrapolating that data I worked
out that we walked just under an hour of
a day on average that's 301 hours per
year or 3.4 percent of our lives but
that's why we go to the gym right to fix
all of this well according to research
by the international Health rackets and
sports club Association the average gym
member in the US only visits the gym
twice a week for an hour each time that
equates to about 104 hours per year 1.19
of Our Lives oh and we spend 33.3 of our
time asleep whoever you are chances are
you spend most of your life almost
completely sedentary